one of your very first tasks in animal
crossing will be to name your island
while there are a number of things in
new horizons you can tweak and change
along the way your island name isn't one
of them so be sure to brainstorm first
and go with something you'll be happy
with for the long haul if you plan on
using any of the game's online features
such as visiting other islands you
should know that others will be able to
see the name of your island so probably
best to go with something that won't
embarrass you later on your island name
will appear often and be referenced in
conversation between you and other
villagers if you're having trouble you
can always look to the internet for some
inspiration there are even random name
generators you can try and as a little
bonus tip here it's also worth noting
you cannot change your name or birthday
either